viii so I first did my first talk about
CSS grid all the way back in 2016 at the
time it was actually only available in
Firefox nightly and Chrome Canary so I
was making things that no people could
actually see just to try things out I
was actually using a whole bunch of
brand new CSS speeches bleeding edge
stuff just experimenting making
sometimes more like abstract weird
experimental layouts rather than real
websites and it was fun but it's not
something you can do at work so now of
course CSS great supported everywhere
except Internet Explorer so it's a
little frustrating definitely around the
same time that I was playing with all
these brand new CSS speeches I was
reading this book by Aaron Gustafson so
it's it's basically all about
progressive enhancement this is the idea
that you can start off with semantic
HTML and you can sort of slowly build in
layers and once you've got that base of
solid semantic HTML users add on some
CSS you sprinkle on some JavaScript and
then you've got a website that every
single person can use back there and I
think his example was order radius right
so at the time this was that the book
came out this wasn't very widely
supported now if you're on Opera Mini
even now this still isn't supported but
you can use it pretty much everywhere
else and if you're on one of those very
old browsers if you're stuck on perhaps
IE for I mean on nature comm we still
have I think four hundred users on IE
for about five hundred on i-5 so these
people are still out there somewhere I I
don't know
what they're doing with their life but
so these people will see a square and
it's like okay that's fine to take a far
more modern example this is me on this
is my personal website on Google Chrome
this is my personal website on Firefox
in a couple I'm this will be my personal
web Firefox so there is a whole bunch of
stuff we can use without really worrying
about it without caring about it without
thinking about it if it doesn't work it
really doesn't matter our website is
still fine and then of course we have
layout stuff which is less fine so and a
half-two way until every single browser
in the whole world is actually
supporting this stuff before we feel we
can actually use it on a production site
so this is back in the day back in 2016
this was this was one of my first just
little weird experiments with CSS grids
and so this is what it looked like back
then in a nightly and in Canary and then
this was what it looked like everywhere
else then for any thought into what is
this actually going to look like in
these other browsers there are today
some big websites using CSS great this
is the Guardian this is what it looks
like in a browser that doesn't support
CSS grades this is the Financial Times
again using CSS grid in this very simple
very basic way not really using it for
everything not really using it as much
as it could do and then here we have the
FT in Internet Explorer you can see it
still looks pretty decent
still looks pretty good but it is a
different layout it's a simpler layout
it does mean that their sidebar is now
kind of further down the page looking a
little bit odd
but it's still kind of fine and I think
if you're taking these two approaches
these two different approaches if make
the website look exactly the same and
kind of just make do with the best you
can do for Internet Explorer I think
this is only the only approach that's
really worth taking because otherwise
what you're doing you'll be creating the
exact same layout in two different ways
and I think a lot of us are just so
excited about using CSS grid that we're
like yeah let's just use it and then
when we have to deal with managers when
we have to deal with product owners when
we have to deal with QA then realize
okay we will make it look exactly the
same and you're actually just sending
people more code more CSS and you're
actually in a way making things more
complicated the whole reason we want to
use CSS grid partly it's so we can do
more exciting layouts more experimental
layouts more artfully directed layouts
but partly is just because it makes our
life easier
as soon as you're writing to layouts to
achieve the exact same thing you're kind
of losing all the benefit so I think the
reality is that we are just going to
have to make do so here is a third
example of a relatively large site this
is stripe most of their customers are
developers and so they can be probably a
bit more make assumptions about what
browsers people are using and further
analytics show you I'm sure
very few developers use using Internet
Explorer if you're a developer who
chooses that browser out of choice then
I don't even know what to say to that
but Firefox has undoubtedly what's
becoming the best tooling for doing
layout stuff and this will actually show
you every single use of grid on a web
page so this is stripe you can see
they've really gone to town they're
using it all over the place to do what
is really a quite interesting layout
I've got to say I think it's one of the
best designs websites I've I really come
across I think they've done a really
good job
but unfortunately you know this is what
it looks like on Internet Explorer which
yeah it's it's not great it's not
readable it's not legible
it's not even usable so these are the
stats as they are right now it's gone
from being almost what seemed like the
only browser to you a tiny 3% somewhat
depressingly
edge actually is still used by fewer
people than Internet Explorer hopefully
we will see this drop down forever but
every single one of these people on
recent versions of of Windows do you
actually have the option to open an edge
whenever they want to so I think we're
just talking about very stubborn people
that are just like oh my god please just
open edge depending on what your
clientele is you can't just make this
decision this is github but this is as
if July this July they're going to
completely stop supporting Internet
Explorer so that's that's one choice but
another way of doing things if you're a
content driven site some of us are
making very complicated web apps some of
us are making Google Maps something very
very JavaScript heavy if you're a
content driven site where you've got a
bunch of HTML you can take to this
approach this is the Guardian in
Internet Explorer 8 this is nature calm
in Internet Explorer 9 we're talking
about people that to avoid that sort of
stripe issue where you just have
something completely illegible something
completely and utterly unusable instead
you just strip out they hate the CSS and
you're left with pure HTML it doesn't
look amazing but it will work and I
think going for it as we see a further
drop off of Internet Explorer users this
will become an increasingly viable way
to deal with old browsers so this is
just using a relatively complicated
media query I'm not going to explain
what all that stuff actually means it's
kind of irrelevant this is basically a
hack this will make your CSS appear
absolutely everywhere except Internet
Explorer and old browsers because we're
not just talking about CSS grit when we
talk about Internet Explorer this is
actually a comparison of Internet
Explorer 11 and the latest version of
Chrome
and if I zoomed in really really closely
you would see that this is actually a
list of every single feature the
Internet Explorer 11 doesn't support
that chrome does support and it's an
ever-growing list considering right now
it's security updates only right so
every single time I see discussion on
the Internet about oh there's a new
feature everyone's excited about it
there's always some guys it's like oh
can you use it in an explorer to which
the answer like forevermore is no you
definitely can't and so I'm sure we're
all sitting cross browser testing a
whole lot of it this is kind of where I
spend a lot of my life just in browser
stack opening various browsers getting
my own mobile phone out which has got
like oh it's seven different browsers on
it because it's kind of easy to run into
a browser blog this is actually the
working group the CSS working group of
the w3c so though the people that
actually make the standards they
actually kind of know what they're doing
better than anyone and yet this is their
website in Safari and so this is why it
can be such such a good idea to actually
use this technique called cutting
mustard which is a technique really
developed by the BBC a few years ago
which you can update to just cut out
internet explorer completely because if
you're not actively checking every
single old browser out there the chances
are you are going to run into stuff like
this and not even know it and you're
gonna have unreadable content illegible
content and unusable content
but I'm sure most of us probably aren't
really there yet where we can just just
say you know what you get some plain
HTML if your internet explorer so this
is this is nature calm this is nature
calm in in next burrow and right now
you're probably thinking why even bother
if you can do a layout with with flexbox
dual flex box and I think when talking
about how G progressively enhance a
layout how do you progressively enhance
the CSS grid if you're trying to achieve
the exact same layout there's really
that not that much point so this is CSS
without CSS grid this is flexbox layout
in Internet Explorer and you can kind of
tell why we actually needed CSS grid
right because this is the kind of thing
that was hard to deal with to actually
have these consistent columns so in the
last talk you heard a little bit about
supports I think the really frustrating
thing about supports is you do actually
have to define your full back layout
first which is is more counter intuitive
really than I'd like it to be so we've
got the margin for Internet Explorer
we've got some styling for Internet
Explorer some maximum wits for the
different columns and then you have to
actually take all of those things away
and remove them so it's it's not the the
nicest code in the world kind of
desperate so just take it out of there
but it can be done if you're happy with
something that isn't quite 100% exactly
the same
and we're not just using CSS grid as
some kind of developer convenience just
to make our lives easier we're talking
about actually less code to sending less
code to people's browsers actually
increase increase book increasing
performance
improving performance and yeah making
out as well as making ourselves I'm
making all our lives a whole lot easier
so these are some refactorings that i've
done relatively recently we did actually
have some layout done in Kotlin which
I'm sure is relatively unusual and was a
little crazy as well as just JavaScript
for doing layout which really obviously
should be CSS his job but there is still
now even though brihat has shipped in in
most browsers there's still a whole
bunch of very useful features we're
still waiting for so obviously in HTML
some stuff has to be nested as we know I
think the most obvious example of that
is the form element right so you can't
have a label you can't have an input
without a form and with CSS grid that
actually kind of matters because it's
only direct children of a grid that are
actually going to be laid out in your
grid and so this is where display
contents will come in really really
handy so this is just sort of slightly
technical explanation from the actual
spec probably slightly easier just to
show a visual representation of what
that actually means so here is a rather
contrived layout a very simple two
column bridge
and you can see the whole form is
actually just inside of one single grid
cell and have much stuff I put in the
form it's all going to be in a single
cell
and as soon as you put display contents
onto onto the form then things will be
laid out into the two columns so that'll
make great a lot lot lot easier to work
with for a lot of edge cases that you'll
run into you
that is actually already has a
reasonable support I think we just make
waiting on edge at this point but it's
supported everywhere else and this is
the kind of thing that I hope going
forward sub grids will help us deal with
so sub grid I haven't been able to play
around with it because it's not actually
supported in any single browser in the
whole world yet but you can see though
it's actually kind of - two grids here
almost you've got the card some self
integrate but then the actual insights
of the cards are also equal to one
another and that's something that at the
moment unless you use specific Heights
and you actually just say this is going
to be this many pixels high you can't
really get that effect and that
obviously means you've got the potential
for truncating content for content being
completely cut through generally
something of what to avoid so sub grid
is really are going to help us with that
hopefully once it's implemented it's not
all completely panned out yet in the
spec but achieving this sort of layout
should be as easy as display sub grid so
all the examples that we've actually
seen of these big sort of production
websites using grid have been very very
simple put a sidebar to the side simple
layouts which is a shame because I think
bridge is such an intuitive and useful
way to set out layout and the first time
I actually started reading about grid
and thinking about bridge everything was
saying like oh you use grid for things
that are in two directions right and
then you use flexbox if it only goes in
one direction and actually create is so
powerful a lot of the time it's more
it's actually superior to flexbox even
for like these one-dimensional layouts
and so we could use kind of grid
throughout like our whole
website but we're probably not really
there yet if you do want to learn more
about progressive enhancement and
dealing with Internet Explorer I do have
a whole article about that and thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]